hey youtubers is charlie so in case you
totally missed it yesterday break
induced a correlated fandom heart attack
they revealed book for is going to
premiere October third so I'll explain
what's happening when episodes are
posting and how my videos are going to
work for it it really is like one of the
best things Nickelodeon could have done
given all that craziness of this year
okay so first things first here is the
schedule book for episode 1 will post
October third to all digital platforms
that book 3 was on that includes ning
com amazon google play store etc for
some reason it's not been on itunes
probably because apple isn't paying
Nickelodeon enough per episode they also
announced book 4 is titled balance there
isn't a whole lot we know about what the
story is there are a few minor things
that have been confirmed like the title
of the very last episode so if you don't
want to know what that is just turn the
volume down so you see this little
spoiler tag go away I'll wait just a sec
okay ready there we go the very last
episode of Korra is called avatar Korra
it's very simple just avatar Korra okay
so spoiler moving on with the schedule
they haven't announced whether or not
they're going to do a double episode
premiere like book 3 or they're just
going to air episode it's one week at a
time it'll affect when the final episode
is and I would plan on them airing the
first two episodes back to back or when
I say err i mean post because it's going
to be digital if you remember they
usually made episodes available on ning
com between 9am and 12 p.m. pacific time
so just adjust based on whichever
international country you're in I know
some people outside of the United States
had some issues accessing Nick calm but
usually there's some sort of alternative
for you guys so hopefully by the time
book 3 gets here everyone will know how
to get the episodes I just please ask
that you don't post any you know
external streaming links you can tell
people about anything you want to tell
them about just as long as you don't
post the hyperlink I know that sounds
weird but it's just a copyright issue
with YouTube I'll continue to post
updates about the schedule as we learn
it it's possible they might take a break
for some of the u.s. holidays or they
could just air them one at a time a lot
of us shows just take holiday breaks
just depending on where they fall in the
year so it's possible there could be
like a week when there's no episode
own but I would generally plant on a
double episode premiere in a double
episode finale in general I would expect
that all the episodes will finish
earring by the end of the year it's
possible they could roll over a little
but I think they'll want to get them all
out before the end of the year I know a
lot of you have also asked about how
this is going to affect my schedule
because I posted that big channel
trailer and coral isn't a part of it so
obviously i'll be adding Korra to my
weekly video list so this is basically
what Fridays are going to look like on
my channel obviously Constantine is
going to be my new you know DC Comics
Friday night TV show since core episodes
typically post online between 9am and 12
p.m. pacific time i'll have plenty of
time to get those videos out before
Constantine starts because that show
isn't too like 10pm so the videos i'll
be doing will look just like the stuff I
did for book 2 and book 3 you know be
sure to subscribe to get it if you're
finding me for the first time I'll also
be doing the weekly Corey giveaway so
it'll be a lot of fun hat tip to all you
guys who are starting a new semester at
school I know it makes it a little more
difficult for you to get work done on
Fridays but hey you know how many people
do homework on Friday nights to be
honest whenever I was still in college I
did do a little bit of work on friday
nights so I feel you guys another big
conversation right now though is turning
to the fact that this is really the
beginning of the end but what's probably
going to happen as we near the end of
book for is I'm just going to let
everyone vote on a new anime series that
we can all watch together you know
silver lining in things going away is
that it always allows you time to find
something new to fall in love with you
know so don't cry yet they'll be plenty
of that happening during the premiere
I'm actually kind of happy going to the
new episodes not knowing a lot about him
there's always a lot of pressure
whenever episodes leaked to watch them
ahead of time which kind of lessons the
enjoyment just a little bit there's
something to be said about the mutual
anticipation that a fandom has when
they're waiting for something together
whenever something leaks it always goes
totally crazy we did see that kuvira
teaser but so far all we know is that
she might be one of the antagonists we
don't know that she's going to be the
main villain and we don't know who else
is coming back let's think about what
the title balance says about what the
story might be I mean it's all about
brokering peace or brokering an
arrangement between all parties involved
between the spirit realm and between the
political powers at the end of book 3
the spirits were still popping up
everywhere taking over certain parts of
cities and the government's were being
thrown into chaos I know the characters
were mostly
localized to the earth Kingdom but I
feel like it was implied that so here's
chaos would start spreading to the
surrounding area and just to put this
out there I don't think we're gonna have
like a downer 70s ending to the series
for any of you that don't know downer
70s ending is like Logan's Run you know
where the movie ends and it's really
depressing and not hopeful at all I
don't think that's how Korra's going to
end I think we'll end on a positive note
it just applies there's a lot of hope
that Korra is going to find a way to
broker an arrangement between the spirit
realm in the physical realm and broken
arrangement between the political powers
in the world the other really big
question is who's coming back I know we
all want to seat often Azula and the
rest of the last airbender characters
come back or the surviving ones the only
confirmation I found in terms of
returning actors that we haven't seen in
a while was from Daniel Dae Kim the
actor that plays the zombies father for
those that don't know he's Hiroshi Sato
we haven't seen him since book one
during last year he did say he was
coming back but since we didn't seem in
book three obviously that meant book for
if you remember the same kind of thing
happen with great Sal I'll where it was
like oh you know she's coming back she's
gonna be playing a villain an evil
female waterbender villain but when we
didn't see anything in book 2 obviously
it meant book 3 so they're just so far
ahead animation is done way after they
do voice work just to give you an
example they were doing book for
voiceover work while book 2 was still
finishing its run on TV that's how far
ahead they are so as of right now they
are headed to New York Comic Con that's
October 9th to the 12th they will be
doing a panel so you should be able to
ask them some questions if you're going
i would recommend that you do that
doesn't mean that they'll never go to
Comic Cons and do panels again but
future ones will probably just look like
the fan organized last airbender panels
usually fans are responsible for putting
those together so for any of you that
you have an interest in doing that you
know Mike and Brian will probably
continue to go to conventions just done
in an official capacity there's no word
on what they're bringing to that
comic-con panel the new york comic con
panel but they're pretty good about
bringing footage from future episode so
they'll probably at least show a clip
they might even screen a future episode
because book for will have already aired
two or three episodes by the time
comic-con rolls around for anyone that
is going to New York comic-con and wants
to ask them a question I just caution
you against asking them about future
avatar series they've already said there
not doing a future avatar series after
Korra so it's kind of a waste of a
question I would ask them more about are
they going to continue the comics is
Nickelodeon intending to continue the
story in other forms of media most
notably the comics the comics is really
just the first place I would look
they've already paid a ton of money for
the rights to Korra and to produce all
these episodes they're probably not just
gonna drop it cold turkey so I would
expect that they will continue the
comics hopefully they'll make some sort
of announcement i'm also really hoping
that someone i'm pointing to all you
guys out there ask them what their next
project is break that is or if they're
not ready to announce it yet and they
probably aren't you know when do they
expect to make an announcement
Nickelodeon might choose to develop more
adult-themed content for digital
platforms so Mike and Brian might choose
to develop a series in that vein they
never said necessarily that they'd never
work with Nickelodeon again even given
all the craziness with Legend of Korra
so it's totally possible that they could
develop a new adult themed animated show
for digital platform that doesn't mean
that it would be another avatar series
though I do expect them to continue to
produce animation break did say that
they had a bunch of ideas that they just
didn't end up pitching a long time ago
that they still want to pitch so those
projects might be what happens next but
they didn't really say what they were I
will continue to follow their career but
like I said as Korra book 4 starts to
close down i'll just ask all you guys to
vote on new anime series for me to do
videos for just something fun that we
can all enjoy it together I'll say the
worst part of a phantom is waiting you
know the not knowing part waiting for
the second part of a two-part episode
waiting for the next series to start you
know not knowing what's coming next I
guess you could say waiting in lines at
comic-con is a huge bummer too but as
you guys think of potential future anime
series to suggest to me you know i just
asked that they be something that
everyone in the world has access to and
that are generally pretty cheap to find
so you know they either have to be able
to stream it or find it on TV generally
i try to avoid doing videos for things
that only a small group of people can
watch it just makes it a lot less fun
and since the core of book 3 premieres
within like the next three weeks i'm
going to just continue to do regular
bonus videos on a weekly basis on
Fridays because that's when new episodes
are going to post i'm slowly getting
into my fall schedule if you haven't
seen it i posted a video you can find
right here where i talk about all the
new TV show
shows and movies and stuff that I'm
doing videos for obviously Korra's not
on that list because they hadn't made
the announcement when I made the video
but you can also click here to see my
book for predictions thank you so much
for watching I'll see you guys tonight
high fives